bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got chat
here with me thank you so much for doing
this
thanks for having me absolutely so you
were the technical lead for
thor chain let's just jump right in what
is the problem that thor chain is trying
to solve
well i think the problem that fortune is
trying to solve is that
it's kind of funny this this ecosystem
has built this decentralized idea of not
requiring any centralized energy to
to be able to conduct but yet we require
centralization to conduct ourselves from
you know bitcoin to ethereum or ethereum
to bitcoin cash or
whatever it might be we we go through
some centralized ending with the binance
or kraken or coinbase or whatever
uh but much better i think from from
almost every perspective if we can move
through one chain to another chain
without being sensors without being kyc
without being
asking for permission in fact when you
want to say you want to
send some bitcoin and transfer into
ethereum on the other side
the only actual requirement of thought
chain is that you can make a bitcoin
signature
that's literally the only thing you
don't want to do anything else you don't
download this thing you have to sign up
for this thing you don't do anything
else
just can you make a bitcoin signature
you can you got it
so when you think through um kind of
both problems i think one of this is a
centralized entity
meaning uh the platforms uh and then the
second thing is what i'll just call kind
of a common unit of account right so
you're selling bitcoin to go to
a stable coin and then you're buying
ethereum um
as an example uh let's start with the
centralized entity what are the big
problems there
uh as to why uh people should not uh
want to
or or or should be looking for
decentralized solutions
that's a great question and i don't even
know where to start because there's so
many places i could talk about to be
honest
so you could talk about the whole black
box element to it not really knowing how
much they have how much
do they are they actually solvent are
they not solvent uh you could talk about
the complexities of it takes weeks to
sign up for one of these things which is
ludicrous my my uh father-in-law just
signed up for
one of these services the micro name
which one and he bought some
ethereum and said like oh you can't take
this off the system off the network for
nine days
you're just like wait why can't i get my
own ethereum i just bought it why can't
i take it off to my wallet
it's just like wait what is this what
are we doing here
this just makes no sense whatsoever uh
not to mention exchange have been hacked
more than
one time let's say uh it's just it's
been a calamity
almost from the beginning starting from
mom gox and we're still reliant on these
systems
and i don't think anybody just like
loves them in a sense everybody's like
we use them because
it's the thing we have to use now but
like i think we all looking for systems
that's more instantaneous that's more
readily available that's
you can just use it right out of your
wallet if you want to use it it's just
that simple
yeah and so then when you think about
the unit of account right that idea that
you've got to go from bitcoin uh into a
stable coin
as an example before you buy another
asset uh
what's the issue there is it just an
efficiency thing is there a cost
element to it how do you think about
that well it's not just
efficiency is one part of it right it is
it takes more time if you want to swap
from bitcoin ethereum it actually takes
more time to do that
on something such exchange than it would
on on 4chan for example
but like the problem is that you're
giving somebody else your bitcoin
which is theirs at that point and
they're giving you like an iou
that you're kind of holding on to
because you want to hold on to their iou
for
whatever reason and then you're going
through a process in their in their ui
to swap
from that to this to this paying fees
along the way
and then at some point in the future
requesting your ethereum out whatever
that
might be this is not a system that makes
sense in the greater scheme of like how
crypto works or how crypto was born out
of it's like i want 100 accountability i
want to be able to
verify that everything is legitimate
everything's like real and that's true
with fortune you can actually look at
the wallets know exactly how much money
it has
how much it claims to have and see
they're always the same like
that's a really important concept that
that we just don't have in a cross-chain
perspective we have it within like
you know dexes within ethereum like that
worked extremely well right was a great
uh platforms we're missing that core
component like
let's move bitcoin to ethereum to
litecoin to finance to
whatever else there's no there's no uh
it's complete neutrality
the network doesn't really care it's
completely agnostic about
what chain or asset you're talking about
it's just we're going to treat everybody
identically the same for sure when
somebody asks you what is thorough chain
how do you describe it
well the most like simple and succinct
way of describing thoracion is that it's
like a like a cross
chain you swap right that's like the
simplest way to put it that's kind of
over simplification in many respects
uh in a larger sense i see it as
the highways between blockchains right
because every blockchain today is a
completely
separated island onto itself and has
very little relationship
or connection to any other blockchain in
the world from for the most part
and so forthchain is creating
decentralized
uh highways that you can move from
blockchain a to blockchain
b and it can theoretically connect with
any blockchain not only in any
blockchain but any layer one or layer
two solution theoretically
you can do pretty much anything you
wanted with it and so when you talk
about these highways really what's
happening here is it allows you for
uh the ability to swap uh directly
bitcoin for ethereum right so one you
don't have to use a centralized entity
uh in terms of uh those exchanges we
talked about but also
two is i don't have to sell an asset
into that common unit of account
i can literally do an asset swap um
between these various blockchains and so
how does that technically work like what
are you guys doing under the hood to
make this
uh possible yeah sure so effectively
the thor chain network has a whole host
of different
like uh bitcoin wallets that it kind of
manages if you want to call it that
and so whenever you send in a bitcoin
transaction
into the bitcoin wallet that's managed
by the network
all the different validators have their
own copy of the bitcoin full node
they're running individually
and they're all looking at the bitcoin
blockchain they're all saying okay i saw
pomp send one bitcoin into you know our
asgard vault address on the 4chain
network
and this is how much it was and this is
about all the details
and then once a super majority of the
notes kind of all agree with your point
each other like oh we all saw the same
thing
send one bitcoin to us and he sent uh an
opera term or like a memo
with an intention of like i want to swap
bitcoin for
ethereum or for usdt or for whatever
else
and so that they all kind of make that
the consensus
that that transaction actually occurred
and then the network says okay
palm tennis won one bitcoin he wants to
get some ethereum out we do a
calculation of how much aetherium that
would be
on the continuous liquidity pools of the
network
and then it sends out that ethereum to
whatever ether address that you
requested it on
uh where you know ox something something
something something something right
and so is this all being built by a
single team
uh is this a distributed thing where
there's just a bunch of kind of teams
working on open source software like how
exactly uh was this originally built and
then how are you guys pushing forward
um you know and kind of continued to
improve or innovate
uh around this yeah i mean it started
with an
initial team for sure um it's very small
too i think it's only like
nine-ish people tennis people on for
that matter but
it's very quickly glue much beyond that
so there's actually like
well over a dozen different teams
building different aspects
of the of the ecosystem in fact like
more of the treasury that the team has
is being spent
to fund ex like other projects and other
groups of people
to build block explorers and to build
dashboards and uis
and you know data science and now uh
analytics
about this that the other thing whatever
it might be so the vast majority of
actual funds are actually going out to
other people or other teams other than
the team that they originated
from and so when you think about why
this is better
um we talked a little bit about the lack
of centralization we talked a little bit
about the lack of need for
uh that common unit of account uh what
else is better about this right is this
something that it's such a superior
product that everyone's gonna go and
adopt it is this gonna coexist with
existing models just talk a little bit
about
how you see the advantages of of thor
chain
uh with some of the other players uh in
the space
yeah i mean i think one of the big
things here that
is quite innovative is that uh that the
thought chain network allows people to
to earn yield on whatever assets they
hold
right so you can earn yield you can
supply bitcoin to the network just
bitcoin by itself
supply bitcoin to the network and then
you can earn yield on that bitcoin and
then come back later and pull out more
bitcoin than you put in system
how does that work well it's effectively
when you put just bitcoin into let's say
the bitcoin pool
on thought chain every time somebody
swaps in and out of bitcoin going one
direction or the other
a little bit of the fee is kind of left
behind in the pool and you're
effectively buying
a percentage of that pool when you put
your bitcoin into it's like oh i'm going
to take on
since 10 of the pool is is my bitcoin
sort of speed
i own 10 percent on the pool so whenever
there's a swap of like a hundred dollars
the fee came through which just say for
rent number
ten percent of that hundred dollars is
mine and i made ten dollars uh
in value from that and my case would be
in bitcoin
and so you can actually like put in a
bunch of bitcoin and then come back
later and have more bitcoin than you had
before and that's not just bitcoin that
can be ethereum that can be litecoin
they can be
tether ripple i mean whatever it is your
kind of cup of tea
it doesn't really matter and that's
that's the first in this industry
and what is the average yield right now
across those assets are we talking about
like one or two percent or are we
talking about like 50
uh it's certainly closer to the 50 uh
you can look at the data
it's freely available anybody can check
and verify you're welcome to
uh it ranges from some assets
uh some pools are much higher like i've
seen some that are like 100 and
something
20 percent or something like this that's
not difficult but it can't happen
uh and the majority are going to be
around 30 40 maybe 50
got it and i'm assuming that that's a
function of how much is in the pool and
then how popular the
swaps are right so if you have very few
people have contributed to a pool
and it's a very popular uh kind of asset
to swap in and out of then obviously
that would lead to a higher
um you know kind of yield and then the
idea would be that's an incentive for
more and more people to join that pool
provide more liquidity and therefore
that return that gets commoditized down
over time
right right even even the the amount of
fee that you pay when you make a swap
through
a throw chain pool is actually based
upon the depth of the pool
and the size of your trade so if you're
doing like if the pool's like
you know 100 units and you're doing a 50
unit trade so to speak that's
like a massive you know you're going to
pay a huge slip fee in that scenario
but so for smaller cap pools you're
going to have
a lower depth to it so people are going
to pay more on the spots and they do
that
we already see that happening uh over
the last 10 months of economic activity
people are willing to pay higher amounts
of fees for you know this smaller cap
pool that's how the economics are
actually functioning today
but for pools like you know the bitcoin
pool or the ethereum pool which can be a
lot deeper
the fees that people will pay will be
far less than you would see on like say
like a unispot
yeah and when you think of uniswap uh
as kind of a um the market leader let's
say for decentralized exchanges do you
view them
as uh just kind of another player in the
crypto ecosystem do you view them as you
know
competition are people making a direct
choice between do i go and actually
trade this asset on unit swap versus use
thor chain
just how do you see the relationship
there yeah that's a good question um
so when we're all fans of of unit swap
they they really do some really great
stuff over there for sure
i don't see them as direct competition
per se for for one i i see
thor chains being more of a short tail
asset than a long tail asset
meaning that you're not going to have
every asset
across the entire crypto space on thor
chain you're going to have
the most economically significant ones
and if you want some sort of small
cap illiquid edge coin you can probably
do that on
unit swap or sushi swap or one of these
guys the difference is that third chain
whenever it manages a new asset it
has additional cost to the network
whereas with unit swap it doesn't have
significantly more cost network so they
can have as many as they want on the
on that smart contract and it does it
scales just fine
whereas thought chain has more and more
cost for every asset that you add
the signed transactions and all these
things that just kind of increase the
amount of
load on the network from that so you're
not going to see a bazillion
assets on thorough chain but even with
the five chains that are currently
supported now
it's already supporting like you know
92 percent of the entire you know
cryptocurrency
you know industry right so it's already
i mean even right now the multi-chain
chaos that we launched a few days ago a
week ago
is already has more access to more funds
than like unit swap or sushi swap
because you have like
bitcoin which is like the biggest most
important thing that like has to be
supported but it has been
largely forgotten and just like left out
for whatever reasons
and this is the first time like bitcoins
being like brought into the fold of like
okay bitcoiners you actually have access
to real d5
with layer one real bitcoin no pegged
assets no rap
any other stuff like legitimately layer
one bitcoin
yeah when you think about uh the recent
shape shift uh
announcement that was really fascinating
to me so eric voorhees
uh it sounds like they decided to take
the
thor chain um kind of technology and
infrastructure
and that's now what is powering their uh
exchange
so in effect what they've done is
they've basically put a front end
on top of thor chain uh and that's where
their users are going and using that
one is that correct and then two talk a
little bit about uh kind of the
importance of somebody like shapeshift
uh
adopting this yeah sure i mean chief
invest is like one of the oldest and
most respected
you know uh across chain you know swaps
like
in the industry at least in my opinion
that's true and like and they've done an
excellent job over the last
you know a few years and their original
vision was to be able to
facilitate trades or swaps without using
requiring kyc and unfortunately that
didn't work out so well because
the technology wasn't there at the time
and they got you know pressure from
regulators to
start doing kyc and all these things we
know the story and so when fortune came
around and
effectively was kind of fulfilling the
original vision of shape shift
they like saw that and they were like oh
this is something we have to get on
board with
and so now they have the ability to be
able to swap between chains without
requiring kyc at all
and if they wanted to they they're not
doing this yet but they might do it the
future they can actually
um have 4chan charge a fee on their
behalf
back to them if they want to using
affiliate feed so you can actually
actually like create wallets that have
interface with thor chain to do some
swap whatever and you can actually the
log manufacturers can make money by
integrating with thorough chain
by using affiliate fees like you know
one base at this point or 10 basis
points or whatever the wallet wants to
charge
per swap yeah what's really fascinating
is basically because you've built that
piece of infrastructure you now can have
these front ends
plug into uh the system right and those
front ends have a way to monetize but
also
uh they're essentially bringing you
customers they're doing customer
acquisition they're bringing you
liquidity
um and so it's a really fascinating
model and ultimately it goes back to
this thesis of like open systems are
going to beat the closed systems
right yeah and uh absolutely naturally
you
you guys have built this open system
that anyone can plug into
yeah it's an open protocol right
no one controls the gates if they're
wide open for anybody use who wants to
use them if shape wants to integrate
with them
more power to them if trustwallet or
exodus or
coindesk uh coinbase excuse me if they
want to integrate
hey go at it you know it's a freely
available network
for anybody to use however they see fit
that's how it should be
yeah absolutely um we talked a little
bit about uh various ways people can
participate so they can go ahead and
they could swap assets using thor chain
uh they can provide assets to the
liquidity pools another element
is they can basically provide a node and
i think that you guys have a very unique
kind of mechanism around the nodes and
they can be swapped out with each other
and just talk a little bit about what
that means for somebody to participate
as a node and then how that entire
system works
yeah yeah so in order to participate at
the node um you have a there's a
capitalistic
kind of um uh race so to speak to who
gets
added into the system so you can you can
walk up and say hey i'm ready to become
a node and then we'll say okay let me
see you there
but every time it churns which happens
every three days or so
uh the network will say all right who
are the most valuable people to churn in
relative to the highest bond right so
right now
on on single chain chaos net that's
about uh
about 13 million dollars like in room
that you have to have
in order to become a validator on on the
network not because like that's
that we as the team had said that's just
literally what the capitalistic markets
dictate
that it you that you make so much
revenue running a node
that it's worthwhile to spend 13 million
dollars buying enough room to run
to run one that's literally what the
like the capitalist markets
dictate uh and so the network's designed
that every three days it churns and
some people get kicked out and some
people get pulled in and that's to
ensure that everybody gets kicked out at
some point in time ever there's a
there's a continuous churn happening
no but there's nobody that stays in
there forever
uh and over time uh every time the
network churns
all the funds need to be migrated
because every time the network turns
new threshold signature like vaults are
created and the old ones are being
retired
so all the bitcoin and all the finance
and all the assets have to be migrated
programmatically to the new bulb and it
happens just every three days
and it proves that the network actually
has access to all these funds
right like if nobody's signed
transactions maybe you lost the keys
we've we've seen this where like you
know certain exchanges you know the head
honcho got arrested
and then like all the funds were locked
up and you're like well
i guess you have it but you can't sign
anything so do you really have it you
know what i mean
and so like 3chain proves that every
three days by moving every coin
every satoshi every every asset across
to a new vault every three days just to
prove
that has access to every single asset
that it holds
i love it uh you mentioned roon uh which
is the token within the thor chain
system describe why you need that
yeah you actually require room like it's
kind of
it's counter-intuitive to some degree
but i'll explain why like if you would
use
something that wasn't really like let's
say use bitcoin as the base asset
of the network which from a
technological perspective is
a little bit impractical due to slow
block times but it is
feasible it is possible but the problem
with that is
if you secure the assets with an
external asset like bitcoin or ethereum
or
tether or whatever the economic
incentives are incorrect in the network
and that somebody will attack the
network and steal all the funds and make
a huge amount of profit
right so say like for for for
kind of game theory this out say there's
like 75 million dollars of bond
that the validators are running with and
then the pools have about
30 million dollars of of assets right
uh and say we're doing bitcoin first so
it's like 75 million dollars of bitcoin
and then
uh 25 million dollars sorry 15 million
bitcoin and 15 million dollars of other
various assets so
because every pool is composed of
bitcoin and something else in this
scenario
so if i were to get enough bitcoin to
cyber attack the network and get like a
super majority so
i need i bought 50 million dollars with
a bitcoin to attack the side of it out
of the 75 million
that are used i can go ahead and take
ownership of everything and have
complete access to everything and do
whatever the hell i want because i have
a super majority of notes right i can do
the hell i want to do
so i can go ahead and seal this 75
million including the 50 million that i
put from the beginning
plus the 30 million over here so that's
105 million so i spent 50 million
dollars to steal 105 million dollars
worth of assets
i'm great i'm doing i'm on cloud nine i
just doubled my money
i scanned the hell of this network i
sold the money i'm like great
right but if it was ruined it's very
different it's actually a very different
behavior so if it's 75 million dollars
of the room
and then 15 million dollars of room here
and the 50 million dollars of bitcoin
and ethereum and various other assets
and say i spent 50 million dollars a
room to cybertech network
so in the end i have a 75 million roon
here the 15 million
that's about 90 million dollars and then
i have 15 million dollars of very assets
but that 90 million dollars i spent that
i have a room is worth
nothing because the value of rooney's
truck is
derived from the value of the network
and the network's hacked
and all the funds are gone who the hell
is going to want to buy a room
nobody it destroys the capitalistic
system
like of that token instantaneously so
i spent 50 million dollars to get 90
million dollars a room
that all that goes to zero and i
actually walk away with all the bitcoin
and ethereum and everything else which
is what's 15 million dollars
so great i spent 50 million dollars to
steal
15 million dollars i just lost 35
million dollars
in that transaction you literally cannot
secure these assets
with another asset like as great as
bitcoin i'm not even [ __ ] on bitcoin
right now
bitcoin's amazing but you cannot use it
for this this application purpose you
have to have a token that's
its value solely derived from the value
of the network itself
and do token holders get a percentage
of those transaction fees in the
liquidity pool as well or does all of
those transaction fees go into the
liquidity pool and for whoever's
participating
that's actually a really great question
so anytime the system makes
income right whether that's block
rewards whether that's um
lp you know swapping all this kind of
thing downstream
we're talking about uh lending and
borrowing to increase
revenue for the network but anytime that
happens that is a i
consider to be a system income and that
gets divvied up between the liquidity
providers and the node operators
in a way relative to the the
the difference between the bitcoin the
the roon on one side and the room on the
other
the network is has a what's called an
incentive pendulum to say that
okay if it's even where it's supposed to
be which is uh one
uh two thirds on the node side and one
third on the
pool side they'll get a 50 50 split
between the two of them
but if they get if the bottom gets too
high and it's like it's over bonded
then the bonders make less money and
more money goes to
the liquidity providers on this side so
that incentivize people to pump more
money on this side or take money out of
this side and move it to this side
to go back to that kind of equal like
equilateral like
pendulum swing of the middle to ensure
that so everybody profits from the
system
no matter what role you're taking into
it and it ensures everybody profits
in an equal way relative to the
economics of the situation at that
moment
and is it possible for somebody to own
roon without
provi uh participating in the liquidity
pool or
uh being a node operator correct yeah
you can you can hardly
in your wall if you really want to you
know more power to you i think but
i think most people aren't going to do
that because you can just turn it into
instead of just being dead capitalist
sitting in a wall not really doing much
for you
why not make it work for you and
actually generate a yield from that
if you want to do that have at it you
know go nuts
if you don't hold in your wallet that's
fine too up to you
yeah what's been the biggest surprise
for you working on this
oh the biggest surprise um this thing it
just felt like this thing blew up so
fast so quick
like like when i first started working
on the project in mid-2019
and you know commuting the first lines
of code and everything like
we even at that time we knew that this
was something interesting something
special but
you you just can't fathom like how far
it will go like it's just it's
almost ridiculous like i remember we
were like just joking around like
like imagine if roon hit like 10 cents
like would that be like
insane and now it's at like 15
or whatever the hell the price is right
now like it was just like it was
to see it kind of go from that kind of
initial vision that the team had
and then grow into this like gargantuan
thing that actually
launched and actually supports
cross-chain swaps just in a way that's
permissionless essentially
such as that censorship resistant uh
is absolutely remarkable i i i could not
have you know i
i can't get over it i love it uh
what's the impact on decentralized
finance regardless of where it happens
bitcoin ethereum whatever
when you have this kind of cross-chain
swap uh does that just provide a
foundation for
more faster um and kind of better
innovation and adoption or how do you
think about that
yeah i like up until this point ethereum
has been kind of like defy king right
like that's pretty
inarguable in a sense and that's largely
because
uh ethereum's programming language was
much more flexible and powerful than
bitcoins was like very kind of weak not
much you can really do with it for the
most part
and then a theory came along and said
hey you can do some really you know you
have a turning complete language called
solidity and you can do all these kind
of interesting things which is great
but once you have something like a
thorough chain that's written on top of
the cosmos network you have a
much more powerful and much more
flexible system that you can build and
construct
you literally cannot build thor chain
like on top of the ethereum system
just like fundamentally just won't it
won't even
come out the door right why not and so
well because
you need value your own the security of
your own network to secure
external assets you can't rely on
ethereum security to
to secure an unknown amount of assets on
bitcoin and litecoin and all these other
things
you need uh you need validator nodes
your own validator nodes that are
incentivized
to be observing transactions on bitcoin
in ethereum and
all these other other blockchains in
order to make that viable or possible
furthermore like even you know a theme
transaction its cost is like goes up
remarkably high
the more complicated a computation is or
the more data intensive it is and
that's not going to be economically
feasible on theory you have to do it on
your own kind of native sovereign chain
which is what fortune is
i think that ethereum will still have a
place in the future
but any d5 application that wants to be
worth its
assault will have to support the
entirety of the crypto sphere not just
the ethereum people
or the these people over here but just
say you can walk up with your bitcoin
with your listing through that or
whatever
and you get treated with the same exact
access as anybody else
so 13 has access to like over 2 trillion
dollars worth of liquidity
around like the crypto sphere and you
know
uh a unit swap has access to like i
think it's like 450 billion dollars if
you do all the year c20s
and ethereum together that's like you
know a sliver relative to what
4chan has access to so the liquidity
will end up being
on a chain like 4chain for sure because
that's where you can actually swap from
one place to another in a way that
actually makes like real sense
yeah it's fascinating uh before i let
you go i've got three questions that ask
everyone then you'll get to ask me one
to finish up
uh first is what is the most important
book that you've ever read
uh most important book ever is a
it's a boring thing it's a coding book
but i'm not gonna say it because
that's gonna be too boring for people i
think more fun answer is
um neil degrasse tyson wrote a book
called uh
astrophysics for people in hurry it's a
great book uh
it really gives you a great
understanding of astrophysics if you're
if you're interested in topics like i am
second question comes from our friends
over at eight sleep uh i used to sleep
like five or six hours
and then i got this uh thermo-regulated
bed basically i make it super cold and
sleep like a baby now
and have become a full convert to the
sleep religion
uh what's your sleep schedule like do
you sleep a lot and how has that changed
over time
well we just launched all that chain a
week ago so it's not
it's not quite like well rested i'll say
that
and also not to mention my wife is about
to give birth in like a week
literally so i'm sure my sleep is gonna
be even worse
you know in the coming few months after
uh my baby girl gets here
uh that's gonna be you know a venture
onto its own for sure
that that's those are two acceptable
answers as to why did not get some sleep
uh last question for you then you get to
ask me one is aliens are you a believer
or a non-believer
oh well
i definitely believe it for sure i mean
if you think about it like
what are the most uh common elements in
the universe the most like plentiful
illness
it's helium in this water helium
hydrogen
uh oxygen carbon and nitrogen those are
the most
most common inlet or most common
elements in the universe
what are the most common elements in the
human body right or there's life itself
well hydrogen hmm what is interesting
not helium helium is a noble gas
doesn't combine with anything so it's
like a block you can't build anything
with
but oxygen and uh nitrogen carbon all
these things we are comprised of the
same things of the most plentiful
resource
on the entire universe so it makes no
sense
if we were the only ones right even even
carbon carbon we are carbon based
because uh the you can make more
molecules of carbon than you can with
every other element combined it's
extraordinarily powerful
uh molecule which is why we're made of
it and it's also five times
more common than another element like
silicon just
conceptually successive similarity to it
so
are they are we around uh other aliens
absolutely sure i mean
if you were gonna make the statement if
you can make the reverse statement so
i'm getting a little tangent here
but if you're gonna make the reverse
statement that we are the only thing
in the universe then you to come up with
a reason of how what infinitesimally
small
pot like thing that happened to us on
this little blue
a pale blue dot uh as as carl sagan once
called it
and i thought that's a hard like that's
a hard idea like nobody has actually
yet come up with an idea of how that was
feasible especially when you consider
that like
there are more stars in the universe
than there are grains of sand on the
entire
planet earth so you it would have to be
so rare that you have to win the lottery
every day for a few years sequentially
that's how like rare would be that we
survived and we are the ones that
existed nobody else exists in the entire
time i have a hard time believing that
it makes
much much more logical sense that the
most abundant resource created more of
us
more like carbon based life forms than
this intestinally small thing we're
talking about where this one little pale
blue dot got something for some reason
it makes no sense to me
i think that may be one of the best
answers we've ever had that was awesome
i'm sorry if i went a little bit of a
science ramp there i'm a little bit of a
nerd in my mind
what one question do you have for me to
uh to wrap us up
my question for you is like what are
your feelings on uh tribalism
like people are you have some you know
bitcoin maxis ethnaxes even ruined maxis
like how do you feel is this a good
thing for the space is it a bath
in the space are we heading in the right
direction in the wrong direction like
how do you feel about that
i don't think the world's binary so i
don't think that it's all good or all
bad
i actually think the truth somewhere in
between um when you think about
uh the good sides of it there's
definitely you know like kind of like
the
hardcore bitcoin argument would be like
oh it's the immune system
right it's the people who don't take
anyone else's [ __ ] they kind of
um you know really uh adhere to truth
and kind of keep people focused and all
of that so
there's definitely truth in that uh the
bad side is
uh you can turn away people who may
actually
uh be you know genuine actors and
interested
and i always say that you can um
you can be a maximalist without being an
[ __ ] as well
right like that is a possible thing wait
wait wait wait what did you say
and and that is uh across the spectrum
right
i think that like uh every single
community every single
tribe has uh extremes to it
and also people who are more centrists
right it's basically just like politics
right
you can have multiple political parties
and then you'll have the extremists in
every political party and you have
people who are more centrists in those
political parties
um and so i think that just we all have
to realize that like
in many cases we all actually have the
same goal or the same finish line in
mind
it's simply that the path to get there
uh sometimes there's disagreement and
sometimes it's actually just people
want to work on different things they're
interested in different things and
that's all okay
yeah yeah that's a great answer that's a
great answer yeah
uh where where can we send people to
find you on the internet or find more
about 4chain
well don't find me i'm not i'm not that
important but you can find uh
thor chain at thor chain um there's lots
of people you can follow within the
community
uh like bitcoin sage and me how brains
and all these great people that are in
this community can go ahead and follow
them
don't follow me i'm useless
is there a website uh where people can
go as well
absolutely yeah thoroughchain.org is one
of our sites you can
check it out read the docs um there's
some great explainers on rebase as well
if you want to get to the nitty-gritty
of it all it is very complicated system
it does take a while to learn um just it
takes a while to learn bitcoin and its
true form release
uh so i encourage people to to look and
to read and understand
the more you read about it the more you
realize that something really
significantly happening here
yeah uh awesome man well listen thank
you so much for taking the time to do
this
uh it's very cool to see people adopting
uh something that you guys have built
so we'll have to get in the future yeah
thanks for having me
appreciate it